[موسيقى]
نعم ، لقد جئت بالأمس بالسيارة ، فقط
لقضاء عطلة نهاية الأسبوع فقط في القيام ببعض التنزه ،
كيف قررت القدوم إلى azer والقيام
بهذا التنزه بسبب هذا
النشاط في الطقس ، هذا أمر رائع ، كما تعلم ،
دعنا نجعلك تأتي إلى أبها أنت تعرف apa
مشهورة جدًا لأنها المنطقة الخضراء
في المملكة العربية السعودية ، إنها جبل جديد كبير ،
إنه أخضر جدًا بشكل أساسي أنا
قادم من إسبانيا ، لذا فإن إسبانيا خضراء تمامًا
في الشمال لذا أفتقد الكثير من
جبلي ، ولهذا السبب أنا
أخطط بالفعل  للمجيء إلى هنا ربما مثل
مرة واحدة في الشهر شيء مثل هذا
نعم للجبال أحب
التنزه وكم من الوقت قضيت في المملكة العربية السعودية
مثل خمسة أشهر تمامًا فقط نعم
حسنًا
العديد من الأماكن العديد من الأماكن أه
شكرًا لك نحن سعداء بوجودك  هنا في
الواقع ، أنت تعرف ما هي في الواقع
بلد جميل ولكن الناس عادة ما
يتحدثون فقط عن هذا أو شيء ما ولكن
هناك الكثير من الأماكن التي يمكن زيارتها في المملكة العربية السعودية
والعديد من الناس لا يعرفون جيدًا
وهي جميلة جدًا وهذه المنطقة
خاصة.  جميلة جدا